the devastating wildfires in northern
california could get even worse today
why because those gusty winds are now
threatening to spread the flames
a fourth person has died in the zog fire
that's near the oregon border
two firefighters needed their emergency
shelters to save themselves
from the glass fire that was burning
through the wine country north of san
francisco
they are just two of nearly 30 fires
that are still burning all over
california this morning
jonathan bigliotti is watching the glass
fire in calistoga jonathan good morning
gail good morning to you wine country
bracing for
another round of destruction wind gusts
expected to reach 30 miles per hour
temperatures
around 100 degrees that's a volatile mix
as these flames continue to burn out of
control deep in the mountains
officials say the next two days are
crucial in containing the glass fire
with winds expected to pick up through
tomorrow
now is the time for our firefighters to
buckle down
the fire has forced the evacuation of
tens of thousands of people
and dozens have lost their homes
including saint helena resident
sean mayer i'm just stunned i never
thought of really fire danger here i
just thought mayhem says his brother
also lost his home as did his 87 year
old father
what was that conversation like with
your father when you called him up we
both cried and he said i can't believe
it you know there's just great memories
of this this property that my dad
owned so it's it's tough
meanwhile napa's lucrative wine industry
now faces an uncertain future
the san francisco chronicle lists more
than a dozen wineries that have been
damaged or destroyed this is the fair
winds
state winery in calistoga which appears
to have lost its tasting rope bottling
operations fermentation tanks
and much of its stored wine and the
owner of the hourglass winery less than
two miles away
says between covid and the smoke from
last month's fires
his business was already hurting even
before
his property burned it starts to have a
psychological effect but
you know we're incredibly resilient
community
and firefighters are working 48-hour
shifts to put out these flames before
the winds pick up later this afternoon
the glass fire stands at just 2 percent
containment
fire crews have a long day ahead anthony
i sure do jonathan thank you